today it's kyle freeland's turn and so
frequently to your point the rocky
starter is pitching of late with a big
league lead this will be the 14th start
of the year for kyle his last eight have
been magnificent
rojas out toward left field this is
gonna drop and one hop the wall so a
good start for rojas
a leadoff double
here's jesus aguilar lunar on at second
to start the day
two balls in a strike with miggy off a
second
and that is up the middle may have
gotten a piece of freelance glove vicky
rounds third he'll score and another rbi
for the national league leader and it's
one nothing marlins
one-two swung out of miss so kyle gets
out far out
for the marlins they go to david hess
this will be his first start this season
pitching in his 13th game era of 432
and that's a base hit for mcmahon he
just keeps on hitting
two on one out and the pitch to charlie
blackmon
is hit to first aguilar makes the play
and the marlins can't turn two
aguilar gets the out at second it'll go
down as a fielder's choice but that
could have easily been either bases
loaded or first and second with a run in
first and third two outs for krone
cj leans on one deep left field way back
and
the leap at the roll it's gone
three run jack c.j
and that one-nothing deficit erased
quickly
[Music]
striking
later yeah joe
got frozen and then his strikeout number
two on the young afternoon for freeland
and
three of the four bats have ended that
way with a strikeout
three strikeouts first time through the
lineup for kyle freeland three to one
colorado middle of two
tom nunes rocky's catchers second start
of the home stand
hold up hold that thought high and deep
and take a good look you won't see it
for long how about a second deck shot
for doug
5-1 colorado connor has the confidence
going he's had a good home stand 2-2
pitch is hit the left field alfaro to
the warning track to the wall it's out
of here
connor jones touch them all time
7-1 rockies on their third
multi-run home run of the
we'll afternoon down at first the miggy
went around he does not like the call by
mark carlson
now ryan addison trying to
shuffle miggy over to the dugout and now
mickey's gonna go and maybe get his
money's worth here
i'm guessing by his reaction that he has
been ejected yeah this is probably as
much about this at bat and this check
swing as
what we've seen really all series long
and gunther gets the strikeout his
second since coming into the ball game
he's retired all four men that he's
faced brinson to right that'll drop in
for a base hit
and brinson will stop at first base a
leadoff knock for
lewis and uh the hits keep coming for
him as well
pretty deep center field run down out
there by hillyard
sam tracked it the whole way rinsing a
leadoff single he stranded 7-1 rocky's
middle of four
this ball is going to sneak through the
vacant right side
mack will go to third it's an 11 game
hitting streak for trevor hit him where
they ain't
just gets the ball off the end of the
bat nobody on the right side of the
infield other than aguilar
well cj crone as hot as anyone in the
rockies right now already has a couple
of grand slams this year
driven deep to left field way back
there's his third granny of the year a
new rockies record
cj crone
makes it 11-1 for the purple
[Applause]
swung on and miss de la cruz gone that's
six strikeouts now for freeland jesus
aguilar will get a chance
and jesus aguilar with a drive out to
left and connor joe can't make the play
stays in the ballpark hilliard will fire
this one in and a run will come in to
score issan diaz with two outs off on
the crack of the bat now louis brinson
and brinson right center field they're
gonna have a little more to show for it
right here a run is in here comes sierra
no throw and it's a two rbi double for
lewis brinson
here comes from campbell
and they will check it third
and he went around so strike three nunez
retired
and now joe panic with the drive out to
right center field carrying off the wall
and panic will slide into second a lead
off double
face it for story
ball to deep left
and reaching up and making the catch is
connor joe
[Applause]
here's sam hilliard one for three with a
single to left center
oh goodness this ball hammered a deep
right and gone
another ball to the second down
and the rockies fifth of the afternoon
and it's 12 to four rockies
and now alex jackson will come to the
plate jackson over two will walk his
first time up
goes after the first one and hits one
high and deep to left joe backing up at
the wall three-run home run for alex
jackson marlins get a little bit closer
in the eighth inning and it's 12-7
connor joe a two-run homer in three at
bats and he'll drive this to right field
jackson looking up it is gone
connor joe
gets his first multi-homer
game as a big leaguer
rockies
[Applause]
jesus aguilar two for three officially
for the right-handed hitting slugger
to a pitch
and that's down the line fair it's gone
and it's gone a home run for jesus
aguilar what a day and the marlins get
one here in the ninth
and a ground ball to second hampton's
got it throws to first and the rockies
had swept the miami marlins
and they have turned in a great week of
baseball at loto they go five and one
as they absolutely pound the baseball
kyle frilling gets the victory his third
of the year